well law of averages has happen sooner
or later so I am fist the first batch of
reviews are starting to hit and the word
is not good not like even like middling
conflicted people's any odds have been
but like it's bad reviews are harsh on
the cast on the way it's shot on the
story on pacing I mean can be fair what
was released for review was only the
first six episodes there's still the
back half maybe it comes together who
knows although if these first six
episodes are as bad as everyone saying
it seems unlikely now I'm not a
professional reviewer I didn't get
access to these things ahead of time so
I haven't seen them but I kind of want
to talk in the abstract yo Marvel's
making a bad product into in relation to
their comic book properties on TV and
film because I would argue it hasn't
really happened up to this point now not
everything they've made it's been great
some of them have been pretty
forgettable some have been weaker than
others some have been a bit of a mixed
bag but in my personal assessment they
haven't made an outright piece of crap
but just statistically sooner or later
it was going to have to happen and the
war I think back on it it kind of makes
sense that it would be on Iron Fist I
mean this is one that didn't seem to
have a hook or a reason for being other
than to be the fourth series leading up
to the defenders I mean II we shot the
movies aside we just limited to the
Netflix shows everything else had a
really serious point I mean daredevil
was was the Iron Man of the netflix has
we want to establish the tone the feels
show that this could work conceptually
so that had a lot riding on his
shoulders but I needed to bring the
superheroing down to the street level so
it came in with a mission and it went at
it Jessica Jones came in with a very
different mission but a very bold one
this whole notion of empowerment and
victimization and the representation of
that through the powers that both the
hero and the villain had and how that
all played out again went in with a bold
tape with a bold mission Luke Cage
wearing it influences on its sleeve
hip-hop blaxploitation the
wu-tang clan that whole vibe of things
they said we are dipping back into an
era and a style of film that's been
forgotten and we're going there Colt a
great and iron fist um I mean I I had
assumed that I think a lot of us had
assumed it would hearken back to you
know classic kung fu movies but not a
lot of what's been said or shown really
supports that I think that was just the
assumption we kind of all made and
looking back on it now and and I always
had this early really the only thing
about this series I was looking forward
to potentially where the fight scenes
because I wanted to be a different kind
of fight scene in terms of you know the
more longer longer tape but not you know
the harsh brutality of a daredevil fight
something more something kind of
Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon II I was
looking forward to that I thought maybe
we get it here but that was really kind
of the only thing I was looking forward
to and that's not just because I don't
know a ton about the character I didn't
really know much about Luke Cage or
jessica jones before i thought either of
those series and i was excited for both
of them because i knew what you know
they were aiming for it i saw their
ambition like cool there was this didn't
seem to me a lot of ambition behind the
series conceptually and everything else
and I wonder if this was a case of they
came up with the idea early on you know
we're going to do daredevil jessica
jones Luke Cage iron fist and then we'll
do the fenders and because they
announced that entire setup say I wonder
if they it just kind of assumed we'll
figure out these things as we go and
they'd always had iron fist last maybe
they figured well maybe that's the one
we'll we'll figure out you know the hook
and everything else and I wonder if it
never did and so what we end up with is
really a true piece of just filling in a
ledger filling in a spot on a schedule
that has no other reason for being again
I'm going to emphasize I haven't seen it
but the more i think about what we know
and what has or not a lot has been built
up about the release of this show and
how much we knew and how you know strong
that the cell was on the other netflix
series and yeah in high
site the writing may have been on the
wall but just Marvel track record have
been so strong up to this point that it
just didn't occur to us that they might
fall on their face with this one it's
kind of the inverse of DC in a ways
because if I see a trailer or piece of
marketing or whatever for a DC property
and it's fine but unimpressive I'm going
to assume the worst because of the
recent history of these movies tells me
that I need to in my head lean towards
the negative if I'm going to round on
rounding down whereas Marvel you show me
some trailers and some footage that is
unimpressive doesn't leave a heck of a
lot of an impression I'm going to by
default favor a more positive outlook
regardless because Marvel has such a
strong track record backing that up and
so it boosts another wise neutral call
but that doesn't mean that the final
product is suddenly going to be good so
maybe though the one lingering question
is will it actually have much of an
impact if this is not very good if it's
not particularly well received it's hard
to know the ratings will be netflix is
really kind of squirrelly about you know
it's viewing numbers so we'll probably
never know but is this you know is this
going to be a major dent in Marvel's
armor and probably not i think at this
point marvel entertainment as a machine
is so well oiled and it's just moving
ahead just with so much momentum that at
this point it will just process the
failure they won't give Iron Fist a
second season he'll show up in the
defenders and that'll be it if they
decide to keep him around I mean you
actually might even decide to kill him
off who knows what if they decide to
keep him around he'll just killed cameo
and other people serious he won't get
his own series again and they'll move on
but it is going to be interesting
because for how long Marvel has been
asked this now it's but it has been
almost 10 years since the first Ironman
and it's been a hell of a run with again
at least in my estimation no true fall
down on their face failures so you know
what it'll be interesting to see how
they handle it how fans react to it I
think I will be most curious to see
whether people who have really bought
into more oval and our marvel fan voices
somebody I get accused of being
whether they will try to defend this
just because it's Marvel or if they'll
go you know you can't hit a home run
every time so they struck out on this
one we move on I'll be curious to see
that because and I'm not trying to poke
the bear on this but you know there's
this is the Internet DC Marvel it really
becomes a thing and it's been really a
weird thing to see certain stripes of DC
fans try and defend things like suicide
squads and I'll just be curious to see
if Marvel fans really are just a direct
equivalent or not or if they'll process
they'll just process it differently I
honestly I don't know I would not be
shocked either way come on the one hand
you know geek fandom a geek fandom geek
fans tend to act the same kind of
regardless of what their love is so I
would not be surprised if there is a lot
of really odd how dare you say this
isn't good it's great ah kind of
reaction from certain strengths of fans
and I also wouldn't be too shocked if
they just kind of shrug and move on
because there's not as much riding on it
that I think that might be part of the
reason that the the people who like or
want to like the the DC movies are
defend them so vehemently is because
there's a lot riding on each individual
film because they still haven't really
built a completely solid foundation so
each one that doesn't work makes the
whole thing weaker at this point
everything under marble so structurally
found one failure is not going to bring
the house of cards now so this case
we're riding on it which probably gives
fans more of a reason to jump to his
defense I don't know if that will happen
with Marvel or not but I will be
watching I am sure i will have people
yelling at me regardless of what goes on
i do plan to check out iron fist because
you know unlike having to go to a DC
movie in the theater I already have
netflix so I it doesn't cost me extra to
watch iron fist it only cost me time now
you know what I get free episodes in it
sucks I'll bail I'm not going to slog
through 13 episodes of crap but I'm
going to check it out we'll see what I
think well if you review on it
now depends on whether or not i feel i
have anything to add to the conversation
I just kind of wanted to jump on talking
about the whole idea of Marvel possibly
having his first out-and-out failure and
what that you know maybe think about
everything so that's it what are your
thoughts on all this guy's what happens
if Iron Fist sucks whatever your
thoughts are just put me down in the
comments let's talk about it don't
forget to Like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at council geeks give a listen
to counsel of geese podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]